[Musique]
bonsoir ravi de vous retrouver dans le
78 nous sommes le mardi 21 novembre
voici les titres la 39e campagne
hivernale des Restos du cœur a démarré
ce mardi mais l'association qui a
distribué plus de 2,5 millions de repas
dans les ivelines l'an dernier devra
pour la première fois de son histoire
restreindre le nombre de bénéficiaires
la cause des difficultés financières
focus sur une antenne
attrape à 9 mois des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pôul emploi Saint-Quentin
en Yveline Paris 2024 et ses partenaires
ont organisé un job dating au Vélodrome
national CDI CDD ou emploi saisonniers
plusieurs opportunités étaient à saisir
auprès d'une quarantaine d'entreprise
nous reviendrons sur cet
événement le concours de chant Tremp
plein des voies revient pour une 9e
édition ce weekend avait lieu des
auditions pour se qualifier pour la
demi-finale on a suivi quelques
candidats et puis l'invité du 78 en 2uxè
partie d'émission ce sera François de
maziè le maire de Versailles il avait
cofondé en 2008 histoire de lire qui
revient avec une 16e édition les 25 et
26 novembre prochains et réunira cette
année plus de 190 auteurs et en plateau
avec moi Gabrielle Gontier bonsoir
bonsoir journaliste de la rédaction de
TV 78 alors dans quelques instants vous
allez nous présenter les informations en
bref à retenir de ce mardi dans les
ivines mais pour le moment je vous
propose de prendre la direction de
trappe je vous le disais tout à l'heure
dans les titres la 30 la 39e campagne
hivernale des Restos du cœur a démarré
ce mardi mais touché de plein fouet par
l'inflation et la hausse de la précarité
l'association sera contrainte de refuser
des bénéficire cet hiver c'est notamment
le cas de ce relais attrape où il
craignent de pas pouvoir aider tout le
monde un reportage
ma 10h le relais des Restos du cœur de
trappe est en pleine préparation c'est
le début de la campagne d'hiver il faut
trier organiser et disposer les aliments
pour faciliter la distribution aux
familles conserve pâte farine sucre
légumes pour l'instant attrape les
stocks sont là mais la crainte du manque
n'est pas loin pour l'instant on y
arrive encore mais nos ramasses magasin
on travaille avec des magasins baisse
quand même pas mal et du coup ça oblige
les restau du cœur a acheté de plus en
plus de produits et effectivement on
s'attend à un moment donné à ce que les
restau n'arrivent plus à acheter ça leur
coûte très cher et on sera obligé
d'impacter ça sur les familles que l'on
accueille attrape 500 familles se sont
inscrites pour cet hiver selon Olga
c'est un chiffre déjà conséquent pour un
début de campagne en raison également de
l'inflation elle a vu une quarantaine de
nouvell famille venir s'inscrire cette
année une situation qui se reflète au
niveau départemental il y a de de choses
il y a effectivement qu'on va être
obligé avec les décisions du National de
refuser des familles puisqu'ils vont
plus rentrer dans dans notre barê et ça
c'est quand même toujours quelque chose
de difficile pour les bénévoles de
devoir dire non devoir dire aux familles
B on peut vous aider sur d'autres choses
mais pas sur l'aide alimentaire et
puisqu'on ne sait pas c'est
effectivement quel pourcentage de
nouvelles famille on va voir arriver
dans les ivelines les restos du cœur ont
constaté une aggravation de la précarité
et une forte augmentation du nombre de
personnes accueillies entre 2022 et 2023
plus de 2,5 millions de repas ont été
distribué c'est 600000 repas de plus et
pour cet hiver le doute persiste
concernant l'augmentation du nombre de
bénéficiaires dans ce relais attrape la
file d'attente est longue ça fait 6 mois
que que je viens ici parce qu'on arrive
pas en fait avec quatre enfants et je
travaille pas et c'est pas facile c'est
très difficile pour moi donc là je
touche que enfin les allocations
handicapé et puis voilà donc j'arrive
pas avec j'ai trois enfants avec le
loyer les charges et tout c'est vraiment
difficile c'est très difficile ça a
beaucoup changé hein depuis l'arrivée du
covid et puis voilà quoi donc ça a tout
changé je suis sans papier euh j'ai
besoin d'aide je travaille mais tu sais
avec
le loyer tout ça c'est trop cher cette
39e campagne desesto du cœur s'ouvre
ainsi sur de grandes incertitudes autour
des chiffres de fréquentation les
premières tendances laissent à pensit
que la vague ne faiblit pas pour faire
face l'association a demandé au
gouvernement un coup de pouce de 50
millions d'euros
supplémentaires et désormais un tout
autre sujet aujourd'hui pôul emploi
Saint-Quentin en yvine Paris 2024 et ses
partenaires ont lancé la deuxe édition
des Jeux recrutes un job dating XXL pour
trouver un emploi pendant et après les
Jeux Olympique et paralympique plusieurs
opportunités étaient à saisir au
Vélodrome national en passant notamment
par la sécurité privée l'hôtellerie
restauration ou encore le secteur du
transport logistique notre journaliste
Clara de fruto c'était sur place
regardez 700 c'est le nombre d'emplois
qui étaent à pourvoir aujourd'hui pour
les Jeux Olympiques et Paralympiques
2024 de 10h à 17h 40 entreprises toutes
impliquées dans les jeux étaient sur
place pour présenter et proposer des
opportunités ces offres elles concernent
les domaines de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration du tourisme du sport
événementiel de la sécurité de la
propreté recyclage et des transports
logistiques énergie j'ai d'ailleurs
rencontré deux entreprises qui étaient
présentes ici aujourd'hui on les écoute
on recherche 6000 postes pour l'ensemble
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
dans le domaine de la restauration on
rencontre des personnes qui recherche on
leur explique justement ce que l'on
recherche et on recueille leur CV de
manière électronique puisqu'on a une
équipe de recrutement dédié qui va les
recontacter ensuite pour recruter
qu'est-ce que vous recherchez exactement
des agents de sécurité masculins féminin
tout type d'agent qui pourrait être
amené à travailler avec nous sur les
Jeux Olympiques par exemple alors on a
tous les types de contrats extra CDD CDI
CDD CDI en passant par des emplois
saisonniers tout type de contrat était à
décrocher le tout en ayant ou pas des
qualifications le but était clair faire
des jeux olympiques et paralympiques une
opportunité pour toutes et tous au total
plus de 2000 personnes étaient attendues
aujourd'hui j'en ai rencontré plusieurs
on les écoute tout de suite j'ai pu
laisser mon CV parce que moi je suis en
reconversion professionnelle pour les
travailleurs handicapés j'ai pas mal de
petites opportunités mais il faut j' sur
les sites internet directement en ce
moment je recherche un emploi je me
cherche je cherche un attendant d'autres
pistes et je suis ouvert au plus de
choses possibles dans mes compétences si
vous avez raté cette journée
rassurez-vous vous pouvez retrouver
plusieurs offres d'emploi pour les Jeux
Olympiques et paralympique sur
poulemploi.fr ou emploi
2024.fr le point à présent sur
l'actualité en bref de ce mardi dans les
Yvelines et on commence avec cette
information Gabriel un trè satellite
ivlinois sera bientôt mis en orbite oui
c'est une nouvelle presse scientifique
pour les chercheurs de l'Université de
Versailles SaintQuentin en Yveline un
nouveau satellite va être envoyé dans
l'espace lancement prévu pour 2025 et il
s'agit du 3è mini satellite conçu et
piloté par le Latmos le laboratoire
atmosphère observation spatiale
l'objectif de ce satellite nommé UVSQ
sat NG étudier le dérèglement climatique
en particulier le bilan radiatif de la
Terre les données seront ensuite
collectées à Guille en cours par le
Latmos l'opération est menée à la fois
par l'UVSQ Sorbon université et le CNRS
et un rendez-vous plus terre à terre
maintenant mais pas moins attendu la 3e
édition du Prix du livre les
visionnaires fait son grand retour oui
Régine cette année encore le réseau des
médiathèques de Saint-Quentin en yeline
propose une sélection de fiction portant
un regard singulier sur notre monde et
traitant des intérê des interrogations
d'aujourd'hui trois romans sont en
compétition pour cette nouvelle édition
les terres animales de Laurent Petit
Mangin panorama de Lilia Hassen et enfin
Rocky dernier rivage de Thomas ginzin
vous avez jusqu'au 26 avril 2024 pour
voter pour votre roman préféré
rendez-vous donc sur le site internet de
Saint-Quentin en iveline et on va parler
de sport notamment avec l'arrivée de
Louis Burton et de Davy Baudard en
Martinique oui depuis ce dimanche 19
novembre les arrivées se succè pour les
imoka sur la transate Jacques Vabre
après de semaines en mer le skipper
rambolitin Louis Burton accompagné de
Davy Baudard est arrivé cet après-midi à
16h58 et 23 secondes à bord de bureau
Vallée il se positionne donc 16e au
classement général prochain rendez-vous
pour le skipper le vent des globes
l'année prochaine et on poursuit avec du
basket l'équipe des Spurs du native du
chénero qu'cour Victor wembanama a
encaissé sa 9e défaite consécutive oui
hier soir les Spurs de Saint anonio
affrontter les Los Angeles Clippers à
l'issue du match les Texans sont
repartis avec une 9e défaite de suite
dans leur valise l'équipe conserve donc
sa dernière place au classement de la
Conférence Ouest de son côté Victor
wembanama s'est montré discret avec
seulement 9 points trois rebonds quatre
passes et deux contres nouvelle soirée
difficile donc pour l'équipe prochain
match pour les sport dans la nuit de
mercredi à jeudi où ils recevront à
nouveau les Clippers de Los Angeles et
bien merci beaucoup Gabriel et si vous
aussi vous êtes témoin d'une actualité
qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le HT 78 news c'est l'heure
à présent d'ouvrir une page
[Musique]
culture et on va désormais prendre la
direction de la verrière la semaine
dernière se tenait la soirée des
écrivains persécutés un événement autour
de la liberté d'expression dans le monde
à cette occasion nous avons rencontré
masbas un auteur compositeur de la
République démocratique du Congo il a
livré son témoignage à Aurélie
[Musique]
lafeille j'ai quitté le pays suite à
plusieurs menaces et agressions par
rapport à notre
engagement qu'on avait et puis j'ai été
agressé arrêté menacé
torturé c'est ce qui a fait que je
puisse quitter la RDC pour rejoindre
l'Europe en
[Musique]
2015 l'atelier des artistes en exil déjà
ils soutiennent des artistes
premièrement dans leur démarche
administrative et dans ce qui concerne
les logements et puis ils font de sorte
que ce que l'artiste garde son cadre
artistique qui soit à l'aise en fait
donc il nous offre des des studios
d'enregistrement des lieux de répétition
j'ai un groupe comme vous voyez là c'est
écrit une PV chez mon groupe PV band un
PV qui veut dire trans quand fait notre
musique on est vraiment en transance et
puis c'est grâce à eux que je suis
devant vous là ce
[Musique]
soir porter la voix de sans voix parce
que la RDC c'est un pays qui est en
guerre depuis depuis plusieurs décennies
tout le monde font font semblant de voir
mais de ne pas regarder ce qui se passe
et il y a des gens qui n'en parlent pas
parce que là on est on est à plus de 18
millions de morts c'est plus que la
guerre mondiale et nous les artistes on
est là pour porter la voix de ces ces
populations
là plus de 400 inscriptions un nombre
encore jamais vu par les organisateurs
du trempelin des voix le concours de
champ yvelinois porté par la voix en
scène ce weekend se tenaient les
auditions à Saint-
et man Lamo 50 candidats ont été choisis
par le jury pour les demi-finales un
reportage de Mélanie
[Musique]
poet quelques minutes pour défendre sa
place donner de la voix pour partir en
demi-finale kimra est de cela elle est
le coup de cœur de sa session des coups
de cœurs mis en place par les équipes du
trempelin des voies pour départager les
130 candidats auditionnés ce weekend ça
s bien passé au départ j'étais un peu
j'étais un peu stressé parce que comme
je disais tout à l'heure c'est vrai que
faire quelque chose en guitare voie
quand on a un silence complet on entend
chaque petite chose qui se passe on fait
pas forcément de balance là on arrive
[Musique]
directement il m'a dit que je chantais
bien que j'avais fait une belle
performance et que je pouvais continuer
trois catégories interprète 17 ans et
moins interprète 18 ans et plus et
auteur compositeur interprète départagé
par un jury de professionnel on a le
critère de la présence scénique de la
technique vocale de on a aussi
l'originalité en fait la personnalité du
candidat qui peut beaucoup se démarquer
et après on a aussi toute une partie sur
l'interprétation de la chanson
et difficile de savoir ce qui se
démarque on essaie d'être le plus juste
possible 50 d'entre eux partent en
demi-finale une 9e saison qui a dépassé
les espérances des organisateurs 400
candidats se sont inscrits loin devant
les 250 de l'année
précédente
VO qui je
suis dès la l'ouverture des inscriptions
en juillet en une semaine je crois qu'on
était déjà 50 candidatures
en moins d'un mois on était déjà 100
sans inscrits donc c'était assez
impressionnant prochain rendez-vous pour
les candidats heureux ce samedi 25
novembre à la salle jacbrel puis le jury
prendra la direction de La Réunion pour
continuer les
[Musique]
sélections comme chaque mardi une salle
du territoire vous donne trois raisons
d'aller voir sa prochaine date ce soir
la salle Jacques brê à Montini le
breteneux nous donne trois raisons
d'aller voir à fleur d'oignon une pièce
de théâtre pleine de poésie pour vous
conv vaincre José Cachin au micro de
Mathilde Francou bonjour José Cachin je
suis maire adjoint délégué à la culture
et à l'événem cel à montinil Bretonneux
si je suis devant vous c'est simplement
pour vous donner trois bonnes raisons
d'aller assister à un spectacle qui
s'intitule à fleur
[Musique]
d'ignon la première raison c'est que
cette pièce de théâtre rend hommage aux
comédes social de Charlie Chaplin et de
Buster kitton la deuxième raison c'est
que c'est un univers de magie et de
tendresse et ça on en a bien besoin de
nos jours et la troisième raison c'est
que c'est une plongée l'espace d'une
soirée dans les années 30 avec un
univers absolument poétique et comme le
disait très bien comme le dit très bien
Jean-Pierre Siméon qui est poète lui
aussi c'est certainement la poésie qui
sauvera le monde alors autorisons-nous
l'espace d'une soirée à y croire alors
si vous êtes convaincu par ces trois
argument moi je vous invite fortement à
venir assister à à fleur d'oignon cette
magnifique pièce de théâtre qui se
déroulera le mardi 28 novembre à 20h30 à
la salle
jacqubrê allez juste avant l'invité du
78 je vous propose de faire le point sur
les PR vision météo de
[Musique]
demain demain matin le soleil reviendra
timidement on pourra observer des
éclaircis sur tout le territoire au
niveau des températures il fera 5°gr à
Versailles rouillé et oudant et 6° à
manentel jolie dans l'après-midi le
soleil dominera la partie sud du
département en revanche le ciel sera
voilé sur toute la partie nord côté
température compté en moyenne entre 8 et
9°r sur tout le territoire et de ain
nous fêterons la saint Cécile tout de
suite l'invité du
[Musique]
78 dis soir revient à Versailles les
passionnés de romans d'essai ou encore
de bandes dessiné ont rendez-vous le
weekend du 25 et 26 novembre pour en
parler avec nous François deasierre le
maire de la ville royale c'est l'invité
du 78 dans quelques jours Versailles va
accueillir le Salon du livre d'histoire
ça se passera le weekend du 25 et du 26
novembre c'est un événement qui a été
fondé il y a 16 ans par le président de
l'association Histoire de lire et par le
maire de versaill qui est avec nous
François deier bonjour bonjour Alors
c'est un événement devenu important pour
la ville ce salon du livre d'histoire je
suppose ah tout à fait c'est un
événement qu'on souhaitait avec Étienne
de montéti faire et dès que j'aiétaé
lère nous l'avons mis en place parce que
il correspond à l'image de Versailles
versaill c'est une ville histoire avec
son château et aussi ses très beau
quartiers historique et naturellement
j'avais envie et tien de montéti bien
évidemment c'est est directeur de figure
littéraire comme vous savez c'est de
développer la lecture parce que la
lecture c'est la base de la culture pour
tous et à Versailles il y a une
tradition de lecture qui est importante
mais on voulait encore l'amplifier voilà
donc c'est conjugis ces deux volontés
c'est à la fois parler de l'histoire que
notre ville incarne et également
développer la lecture l'objectif c'est
de rendre l'histoire et la lecture plus
accessible à un large public absolument
et on voit le livre historique s'est
beaucoup développé ces dernières années
il y a un lectorat fidèle qui apprécie
pouvoir voir à la fois le plaisir de la
lecture et puis quoi de plus passionnant
que de découvrir des biographies et de
découvrir une époque à travers la
lecture et alors d'année en année ce
salon s'agrandit cette année pour cette
16e édition il y a environ
190 auteurs c'est un moment de rencontre
d'échange pour eux oui ABS ou on a
beaucoup développé aussi à côté
évidemment la présence des auteurs et de
la signature puisque traditionnellement
dans les salons du livre vous avez les
auteurs qui sont là et qui mettent des
dédicaces et on a d'ailleurs choisi de
faire ce salon quelques jours avant Noël
parce que c'est une occasion beau cadeau
voil mais on l'a développé alors d'abord
vers les enfants il y a donc la présence
d'une tante une grande tente dédiée aux
enfants qui devant la ville de
Versailles devant la mairie de
Versailles c'est symbolique et alors
quels seront les auteurs les plus connus
qui seront présents alors il y aura
beaucoup d'auteurs connus mais alors
vous avez plusieurs catégories vous avez
les les auteurs qui sont par exemple des
grands hommes politiques donc Alain Jupé
sà Alain Jupé j'aurai l'occasion
d'ailleurs ça devient un rendez-vous un
peu pour lui oui oui oui oui bien sûr
chaque année on revoit des grands
politiques qui aiment écrire où on
revoit surtout des historiens bien sûr
parce que le principe c'est les livres
qui ont été publiés dans l'année or vous
avez des historiens comme Petitfils
également qui sont assez incroyables ils
arrivent à faire un livre tous les 2 ans
ou et et pourtant des livres qui sont
extrêmement fouillés très riches sur le
plan historique puis vous avez aussi des
journalistes cette année vous avez am
Kota qui a été une journaliste
essentielle de la 5e République qui a
lit écrit un livre sur la 5e République
et vous avez aussi bien sûr des artistes
euh je pense à Laurent Dutch par exemple
qui est bien souvent ou des gens qui ont
des profils atypique comme Christophe
Barbier qui est
entre le grand euh spécialiste de
politique grand journaliste spécialiste
politique et également amateur fou de
théâtre qui écrit tantôt un livre sur le
théâtre tantôt un livre sur l'histoire
politique voilà après vous avez les
nouveautés de l'année et ça quelles
sont-elles alors ces nouveautés les
nouveautés de l'année c'est alors j'ai
pas le programme détaillé en tête mais
par exemple am Malou qui est tout même
très grande
figure de aujourd'hui la littérature qui
sera là parce que il vient d'écrire un
ouvrage alors il y a 6 ans vous avez
lancé le prix youtubeur
d'histoireou quels sont les vidéos qui
ont été sélectionnées cette année est-ce
que vous pouvez voilà nous expliquer un
petit peu ce qu'est ce prix youtubeur de
l'histoire alors le prix youtubeur de
l'histoire moi-même j'aiété le premier
surpris à voir ce qui existé aujourd'hui
sur
Youtube autour des initiatives prises
par donc des passionn histoire qui
utilise Youtube pour mettre des
émissions alors général assez courtes
mais qui sont remarquablement bien
faites et donc il y a une communauté
très importante qui s'est créé autour
des youtubeur passionné d'histoire et
alors je moi j'étais je suis pas un
spécialiste de YouTube he je vous dis
très honnêtement
et donc j'ai plutôt eu le plaisir de la
découverte j'aurais encore le plaisir de
la découverte ou des gens qui ont des
initiatives passionnantes dans ce
domaine et souvent avec beaucoup
d'humour d'ailleurs et une façon
présenter l'histoire qui permet
d'étendre les publics et c'est ça aussi
la volonté ça permet d'attirer les
jeunes d'attirer les jeunes d'un terrain
autre public et et c'est notre souci que
ça soit vis des jeunes il y a aussi des
opérations qui sont dans les lycées à
l'occasion de ce festival il y a il y
aura deux présentations de film aussi
voyez qu'on parle de l'histoire un peu
sous différents supports mais toujours
tout même avec ce primat accordé au L
Liv parce que le livre c'est la
conservation c'est la mémoire collective
en fait et la nouveauté cette année
c'est la dictée de versaill pourquoi
mettre en place une dictée pour le Salon
du livre al parce que nous avons ici une
association qui depuis longtemps fait si
vous voulez des dicté très bien
organisé et qui a du succès et là on a
décidé si vous voulez on a proposé à
cette assoation de conjuguer le jour
donc de la dicté qui avaient l'habitude
d'organiser avec la manifestation
histoire de lire donc il y a plusieurs
rendez-vous qui vont aussi se succéder
va y avoir des conférences des débats
mais aussi la projection de deux films
vous en avez un petit peu parlé il va y
avoir Napoléon le mardi 21 novembre et
Jeanne Dubarry jeudi 23 novembre là
aussi c'est important de projeter des
films d'histoire là c'est des
avant-premières donc c'est l'occasion si
vous voulez de même que ce festival
histoire de l met en avant les dernières
productions littéraires sur le thème de
l'histoire et bien là puisqu'il y a deux
films qui sont des films de grand public
qui viennent de sortir qui vont sortir
sur l'histoire c'était l'occasion de
pouvoir les diffuser et bien merci
beaucoup François deier d'avoir répondu
à nos questions alors si vous êtes
intéressé notez-le bien dans vos agendas
le Salon du livre d'histoire c'est le
weekend du 25 et 26 novembre à l'hôtel
de ville de Versailles à la prè
préfecture des Yvelines à l'Hôtel du
Département et à l'Hôtel Du Barry le
billet est au prix de 2 € et il est
valable 2 jours vous retrouverez le
programme complet sur le site internet
histoiredelire.fr et c'est la fin de ce
78 demain vous retrouverez Mathilde
Francou à la présentation en attendant
je vous souhaite de passer une
excellente soirée sur
[Musique]
tv78